crazy I got a lot of flavor coming out
of Texas man hell yeah but man we just
I don't know how to say it we're just
Southern yeah it's like The Best of Both
Worlds kind of you guys got great
Mexican food not as great as here but
great don't do that dog so we'll have a
whole argument what are we talking about
what are you talking about LA Mexican
food is superior to Texas are you
[__] me son
it's not even close not again what do
y'all use for video what kind of media I
use y'all use goat yeah see nah that's
where you're [__] up we use fajita
see right
you know who but you know really has the
best Mexican food in San Diego because
it's just Tijuana it's like you go to
like Chula Vista San Diego got that [__]
out here
oh yeah okay yeah come on Texas got cool
Mexican food but it's like this is my
dog ybe right here
what's up what's the hood name I'm from
West Covina City West Covina shout out
is that the 562 626 look at me [__]
up my shout out shout out I think every
time I go through West Covina I get
Raising Canes oh yeah
hey post Malone got that pink one
a pink Raising Cane in Utah
that's [__] ridiculous I want to go I
loved Utah we went to Salt Lake City
downtown Salt Lake City the Mormons is
out bruh bro yeah it's cool though
Hey whenever I heard I was going to Salt
Lake City I started looking up videos of
Mormons in them dog these [__]
moved a house like they they like they
had the floor out you know what I'm
saying and they they were all standing
up like with the [__] the base you
know what I'm saying holding that [__]
and they were in in like bro like it was
like they were all in sync and the way
they [__] maneuver together and work
together is like Mormons are great
people so I went to high school in a
Mormon like they like they gonna survive
well they also you know they don't [__]
they
can't thrust they put the dick in and it
has to sit there until the guy comes you
[__] me no yeah soaking
nah yeah
hold on wait a minute they can't thrust
it's against their religion to thrust
soaking in that [__]
so if you're like a Mormon woman low-key
your kegel game got to be crazy
holy [__] that's I wanna bro I want to
knock one of those man Bama Jammers down
uh God damn yeah
that's crazy if that was the case if I I
would just like I would just like
squeeze as far as I can in there and
like and just sit there you know what
I'm saying like a full-on I think that's
what they do that's because they have to
they can't waste uh a seed yeah so like
every nut has to be for a child that's
why if you notice a lot of more dude
people yeah I'm Gonna Knock plenty of my
kids off the [__] down the
drain yeah pop that hoe out one time
you ever have to pay for an abortion no
sir good for you Nosa yeah that's a
rough thing yeah I was almost giving up
for abortion my nanny was like what the
[__] no wait what yeah my mom my mom was
gonna get me up but because her mom was
like what are you doing like how old was
your mom when she had you you don't make
me asking younger I don't know she was
26 she was 26 when she passed and she
passed and 07 I was eight
and 18. damn 19 it's all right that's
crazy I had my son when I was 17. that's
cool man I want kids I want more now
like I wish I started when I was 20.
well you know what I was I was three
kids deep right now really [__] yes
that's a wild that's a very Mexican
thing to wish
Jesus bro having kids just fight you got
kids have a kid's father who got feed I
know that [__] man that's just fine
you're about to go on a tour and [__]
yes it's cool as [__] bro you got to get
all this rap star [__] out first like
you're you gotta get the rap rapper [__]
out of you like for real you got to go
through this without worrying about like
FaceTiming at the end of the night okay
check me out that's why I'm boom get her
pregnant right now that way the first
nine months about first nine months in
the first like bro I I don't got my and
you know what shout out my dog e because
he helped me you know what I'm saying
he's the one that broke it down to me
like this and he was like what you
should do because I was talking about I
was like I want kids and all this and
that I was like should I wait should I
should I what should I do right and he
was like that's what I'll take he said
the first you know what I'm saying he
said this is how he feel of course the
first nine months I ain't got to be
there the first two years of the baby
being born I got that's all Mama and
grandma said right I don't got to be
talking to my baby until my baby can
fully comprehend what the [__] I am
telling it so just gone for two years
not gone of course
look gone no but like
but like I could go do what I got to do
that way why you handling all that I'm
handling this so we can chill right
right right right you know what I'm
saying of course I'm gonna be in the kid
life I'm not gonna miss the the baby
being born I'm not gonna miss times
where I'm talking to it in the belly you
know I'm gonna be here for that [__] but
baby I got [__] to do